I had this meeting with a
big studio Hollywoodcasting director.
and he looked at me and he said,
"Everybody knows you're a
beautiful,talented Black girl.
But what do I do
with a beautiful, talented Black girl?
Do I put you in amovie with Tom Cruise?
Does he kiss you?
Ugh.
Who goes to see that movie?"
He hurt me so deeply,
Iwas actually thinking about quitting.
Until ...
I started to think.
He said that everybody knew
that I was a beautiful,
talented Black girl.
So whatwas meant to break
me did not break me,
it built me up.
And I walked out of there giving
myself permission
to take up space in Hollywood,
knowing that I belonged there
nomatter what anybody
thought about me.